marie-france tout le bonjour bonjour à
les niveaux vie bonjour aux auditeurs et
auditrices de martinique 1ère vous êtes
secrétaire générale adjointe du séduire
diem et vous étiez candidate sur la
circonscription de fort de france où
vous avez obtenu 344 suffrages
surprise dans toutes les rédactions un
communiqué du grand ensemble et pumba
pays en chance appelle à voter pour
philippe edmond-mariette dans le centre
et francis carole la forme de france et
ne donne pas de consigne de vote dans le
nord et dans le sud
legrand semble epoupa pays à un champ ce
qui prend un communiqué le gant semblait
n'était pas une alliance de gestion pour
la ctm alors j'avais déjà rectifié
quelques interprétations dans le nom et
ne s'agit pas de ne pas prendre de
consigne de vote mais nous disons très
clairement aux électeurs que pour nous
aucun des deux nous n'accordons de
confiance à aucun des deux n'est à brno
nestor azérot n'y a pas filer à la
rigueur c'est plutôt vote blanc c'est
plus donc c'est pas à temps le nord
parce que ce n'est pas si facile s'agit
pas de dire vous faites ce que vous
voulez aux électeurs choisissez entre
à zéro ou choisissez l'entrepont fils il
s'agit très clairement de dire aux
électeurs votent blanc nous aucun des
deux candidats n'a notre confiance et
que
nous ne racontons effectivement aucun
crédit à ces saisies ces deux candidats
très bien alors je reprends ma question
le grand semblait n'était pas une
alliance de gestion à la 7e le grand
ensemble est effectivement une alliance
de gestion à la ctm mais dans des
différends communiqué que nous avons eu
affaire y compris le communiqué du rdm
si vous l'avez bien euros lui le
secrétaire général claude lise disait
que notamment sur fort-de-france que
chaque partie était libre d'aller à la
bataille et que nous devrions nous
retrouver au second tour et que nous
soutiendrons le candidat du grand
ensemble et pour ben pays en chance le
mieux placé donc c'est tout à fait
normal que le grand semblait poma payant
chance se retrouver tout à fait
normalement et qu'on puisse discuter de
la suite à donner dans ses alliances
d'alliance à la 7è d'alliance de gestion
parce que ça a beaucoup été répétée et
que ça n'avait pas on nous a aussi dit
que ça n'avait pas vocation à s'étendre
d'alliance donc de gestion vous avez
transformé cela l'alliance politique
c'est une alliance de gestion et c'est
tout à fait normal que des gens qui sont
aux affaires
et naturellement on a des orientations
politiques que l'on souhaite voir mettre
en place pour le pays et c'est tout à
fait normal que l'on du second tour nous
nous retrouvions d'une élection aussi
primordial essentiel que les élections
législatives puisque cela devra et
pactes et naturellement le
fonctionnement les aides qu'ils auront
est accordée à la collectivité la
politique puisque le député doit est
appelée à accompagner les différentes
collectivités donc c'est tout à fait
normal que nous nous retrouvions pour
pouvoir donner une orientation tout à
fait expliquez-nous comment cela s'est
passé est ce que c'était la réunion du
tout le groupe du grand ensemble et
aubiet ce que ça s'est passé avec les
trois signataires c'est à dire claude
lise yan monplaisir
alfred marie jeanne qui avait exactement
je ne vais pas entrer dans les détails
puisque nous sommes les organisations et
les différents partis sont libres de se
réunir mais non le grand ensemble est
pour bat pays en chances étaient réunis
c'est à dire tous les mondes qui était
d'y soigner puisque naturellement à
c'était un continue de fonctionner donc
si jamais il y avait les candidats ni
l'or et soutane nous aurait tous ceux
qui étaient disponibles étaient là tout
ce qui était disponible était donc
présent à cette réunion verra qui n'ont
pas pu être là parce qu'ils avaient
d'autres obligations ou mais nous étions
dans la grande majorité présents à cette
réunion
cette année ans connaît déjà son premier
coup de couteau un peu de quoi tout
canif dans le centre car nous sommés
déjà sa position elle ne donne aucune
consigne de vote
elle est clément du grand ensemble booba
payer ensuite car les moussons entre
hier et aujourd'hui donc je fais mieux
je ne sais pas si elle maintient sa
consigne de vote
bon maintenant c'est la même chose à
aucun de nous nous ne sont pas des
dictateurs au niveau de la coque de la
duke ont semblé pour ben payal chance le
groupe a un prix donc sont en toute
conscience politique
un fait le choix maintenant on peut
comprendre parce que vous savez lorsque
vous allez dans une élection où êtes
seddouk est sûre le tbs évoqué qui
avaient des ressentis des véhicules donc
cela peut parfaitement se comprendre
qu'elle garde sa position mais moi je ne
l'est pas eu personnellement je n'ai pas
échangé personnellement long ça sera
très difficile pour moi de vous donner
plus de détails sur sa prise de position
7 soutient son futur contrat quelle
forme
par exemple pour la campagne de philippe
edmond-mariette ou bien celle de francis
carole vous allez mener campagne avec
francis cabrel zazie paix à des meetings
des prises de paroles mais quand on dit
c'est très clair et c'est vrai que
j'avais été très étonnée et je pense que
ça aussi un petit peu mille douter le
flou dans l'esprit des électeurs laissé
entendre qu'il y avait un problème d'une
difficulté entre carole et - club à lima
et le mime et nous non c'était nous non
premier tour c'était une action tout à
fait démocratique
il était pas autant que le ndm l ex
s'exprimer et là on avait bien dit que
le candidat qui ont été le mieux placé
serait soutenu donc je ferai campagne
avec francis parce que pour moi il est
impératif de faire barrage aux pnc sont
en inde et put et son temps qui n'a pas
travaillé pour la martinique qui allie
ses encours de dette très important au
niveau de l'ex conseil régional nous
attend d'avoir miguel laventure par
exemple la campagne et miguel a très
clairement dit comme il l'avait dit au
premier tôt qu'il fera campagne
mais oui oui nous tous nous serons
présents tout ce qu on sera derrière
français sans aucun problème les plus de
moi d'ailleurs j'ai appelé francis par
le soir parce qu'elle est et sur les
plateaux télé mais dès le lendemain j'ai
appelé francis et j'ai dit francis pour
un tir manqué salon café le sud
oui il ya un pacte de non agression
entre
sylvia cei sous talent et jean-philippe
du lot oui c'est un pacte de non
agression et d'ailleurs on était tous
réunis autour de la table
et comme au premier tour en tant que
nous sommes dans la dans la suite
logique et nous avons bien dit
clairement qu il fallait
ben quand que chacun mène sa campagne et
que chaque parti soutiendra son candidat
d'accord donc on ne va pas relever il
n'y a pas deux frères ennemis on va pas
se tirer dans les pattes je ne vais pas
je ne vais pas vous dire combien je peux
pas présumer déjà de ce qui pourrait
être dit ou pas dit dans une combe dans
la cophan bon c'est toujours que et à
des gens qui n'ont dans des ddd des
orateurs dans l'élan de la campagne
des fois mon mais au niveau des
candidats au niveau des partis il est
convenu et nous ferons tout pour faire
en sorte que les choses se passent au
mieux est ce que nous aurons à nous
retrouver de toutes les façons pour
gérer la colère t il à faire campagne
pour jean-philippe naylor dans le sud je
vous rappelle et vous avez vous même ici
en martinique 1ère et sous les médias et
théologie claude lise ou parce qu'ils
les avaient déjà il a été déjà il a
commencé à faire campagne ou jean
philippe blanc
donc oui s'il faut les forces d'ailleurs
jean eugène blanchet est très investi
dans la campagne de jean philippe houzé
long dont le sud est ce que ça veut dire
que
dorénavant à chaque élection au deuxième
tour voire même peut-être au premier
tour il y aura une alliance grands
semblent époux bas pays en chansons
dorénavant les parties et d'une manière
générale il faut que vous sachiez que
les partis qui composent l'alliance
grand semblait potvin pays en chant ce
sont des pans entiers tout à fait
responsable et autonome avec la liberté
de choisir leurs méthodes et leurs
stratégies
donc lorsque nous jugeront qu'il faudra
que dès le premier tour que nous soyons
ensemble nous son sens lorsque nous
ferons le choix d'aller séparément nous
le ferons en toute liberté est
dorénavant il faut que les électeurs et
des électrices comprennent qu'il s'agit
là de l'expression de la démocratie
d'accord ça veut dire que par exemple
pour pour quelques ailes prochaines
élections ben si mal élu municipal ça
veut dire qu'il peut avoir une liste ou
bête de candidat unique pour les
municipales les parties vont
naturellement se retrouver moi je suis
ou un dm je vais retrouver ma direction
du et indiens et nous allons réfléchir
savoir si nous ferons une liste si nous
y voilà
c'est possible tout et ça toujours été
possible et toutes les spéculations avec
que ma paye en chanson this traduit
toutes les stratégies eux sont
aujourd'hui possibles parce que je vous
répète nous sommes des partis tout à
fait libre donc nous allons puisque je
suis membre de la direction du parti
je vais retrouver mais mais mais les
responsables du parti du candidat mais
nous allons réfléchir ensemble à quelle
sera la meilleure stratégie
non seulement pour le rdr mais pour pour
la ville de fort de france
est ce que pour le renouvellement de la
ctm on peut s'attendre dès le premier
tour ça alors peut-être qu'on fait de la
politique fiction mais dès le premier
tour à un grand ensemble est pour bat
payer un chance d'anglais puisque
pourquoi aller sur ses propres forces
mais c'est tellement nous ajouter là on
va déjà trop loin nous avons
collectivités aujourd'hui à gérer
faisons au mieux pour que les choses
avancent une collectivité que nous avons
trouvé avec un encours de dette très
important une collectivité où il ya
beaucoup d'attentes beaucoup de besoins
d'une population grande souffrance
voilà des gens concernant la
collectivité territoriale ce à quoi nous
nous attelons à faire aujourd'hui
je crois que en temps et en heure nous
allons nous retrouver déjà pour faire le
bilan et pouvoir ensuite qu'est ce que
nous comment nous nous organisons pour
déjà la prochaine élection mais là
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
élection législative
faisons-le élections législatives
marie-france tour je vous remercie bonne
journée sur notre antenne
[Musique]